[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay amazing so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
we don't make mistake and just don't do
it yeah well tonight a fan named Jason
bar-ilan
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened when I introduced recent
musical guest John Legend
[Music]
hey Conan thus far everybody show last
night with the nine-time Grammy
award-winning John Legend but I couldn't
help but notice that you introduces
album upside down
please give a huge welcome to John
Legend maybe next time you'll spend more
attention to detail and maybe actually
use that fancy Harvard degree of yours
KRCG 1 4 3 1 deuces
I think he mispronounced douches yeah
calling out to his bros I like his look
too he's got ya with a scarf for IND
entity' plunking on a Yamaha keyboard
makes your neck yeah well anyway sorry
Jason but you are dead wrong that album
cover wasn't upside down I was upside
down yes in fact the entire set was
upside down that's something I do at the
end of the show every night to entertain
the studio audience I turn the entire
set upside down don't believe me well
here's a behind-the-scenes look at how
that John Legend intro was made okay
ready for the intro yeah you bet okay
let me just uh buckle up real fast here
there we go and alright ready
okay okay is the yeah is the album
right-side up now oh it's perfect
perfect good okay I just hope the glue
doesn't give out on my mugs or my
microphone man I do hate what this does
to my hair
[Applause]
let's do it please give a huge welcome
to John Legend
yes well we win again so the challenge
still stands if you think you've spotted
an error
[Applause]
[Music]
if you think you've spotted an error on
our show reported a team koco.com / ha -
Dan era we'll sorted out right here on
the air let's see if you have what it
takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro